let's talk about you you could have been
anybody you know but very luckily you
ended up being the very specific
wonderful you that you uniquely are so
how'd that happen what are the odds well
there's a countless multitude of factors
that contributed to you being you and
all your spectacular wonder but let's
take a very hypothetical look at a more
of three of them your parents meeting
your parents sticking together and your
parents having a child that is the
specific combination of reproductive
cells that resulted in your magnificent
residency on this planet so let's look
at your parents for the purposes of this
scenario let's give your dad the benefit
of the doubt and say that between the
ages of 18 and 40 he at least interacted
with one new woman every day in some
small way that means he'd have
socialized with roughly 8,000 women what
a popular guy and let's say assuming
he's not a hermit in the woods that he
very well could have potentially met
anyone from say Oh a tenth of the
world's female population which would be
about 360 million the opposite your
mother was in that tiny group of people
that he met are about one in 45,000 now
there's no guarantee that they'll get
along so let's say that your father was
engaged in a quality conversation with
Oh 1 out of every 10 women he met from
there let's assume that out of those
women he went out on a date with one out
of every 10 and let's say out of those
women he settled down with one and there
was a 1 in 10 chance of those two crazy
kids decided to stick it out and let's
give him a 50/50 chance of sticking
together and deciding to have kids
that's 1 out of 10 times 1 out of 10
times 1 out of 10 times 1 out of 2 which
equals 1 in 2000 sorry
apologies in advance but let's talk
about your parents having sex the
average male produces about 525 billion
sperm cells in his lifetime the average
female has about 300,000 eggs at puberty
but releases around 400 in her
reproductive lifetime so out of all
those cells there was one unique sperm
and one unique egg that needed to match
up perfectly to make you specifically
and the odds of that happening are kind
of staggering one in 210
so if you want to factor in your parents
me sticking together and having sex to
make you specifically the odds are about
one in 45,000 times one in 2,000 times
one in 210 trillion which comes out to
about one in 18.9 sextillion which is a
whole lot of zeros so let's just say
that you are pretty lucky to be here and
frankly we're all pretty glad it worked
out for you